Saturday morning, Chicago, four days after the Department of Homeland Security officially released its new policies on deporting undocumented immigrants. This is a workshop for the people targeted by those policies at the Mexican consulate. And it's packed. They had over 100 seats in this room, and when those filled, they added a second room. And then a third. People stand in the back.
周六上午，芝加哥，国土安全部正式发布新的无证移民遣返政策四天后。这是墨西哥领事馆为受这些政策影响的人群举办的研讨会。这里座无虚席。会议室原本有100多个座位，坐满后，他们又增设了第二个房间。接着是第三个。人们只能站在后面。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
Good morning to all of you, says an official from the consulate, Carlos Valera Paulino.
领事馆官员卡洛斯·瓦莱拉·保利诺向大家问好。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
Truth is, we didn't expect this many people.
老实说，我们没想到会有这么多人来。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
But we understand the situation is worrisome, and that's why you're here.
但我们理解局势令人担忧，这就是你们在这里的原因。
The president has been saying over and over that his new deportation rules are targeted at drug dealers, murderers, gang members. But if you simply read the guidelines, they say in black and white that's not what they do. The enforcement priorities now include all kinds of people who are not drug dealers, gang members, or serious criminals of any kind. Nearly anybody who's undocumented is covered. And it's been widely reported some of these non-criminals have been picked up already.
总统一直反复声称他的新驱逐规则是针对毒贩、杀人犯和帮派成员的。但如果你仔细阅读指南，上面白纸黑字写着并非如此。现在的执法重点包括各种并非毒贩、帮派成员或严重罪犯的人。几乎任何没有合法身份的人都在范围内。据广泛报道，一些并非罪犯的人已经遭到逮捕。
Lots of people don't know this, but Chicago is a very Mexican city. Over half a million people with Mexican roots, a fourth of them undocumented. And the consulate sees itself as their ally. We care about you and your kids' future, one official says to the crowd, which is definitely not the message they've been getting lately from the American government. The consulate convened this panel explaining, OK, here's how to plan for the possibility that you'll get detained and deported. Like, OK, if you're taken, what'll happen to your kids? How do you plan for that?
很多人不知道，芝加哥是一座非常有“墨西哥特色”的城市。超过50万人有墨西哥血统，其中四分之一没有合法身份。领事馆视自己为他们的盟友。一位官员对人群说，我们关心你们和你们孩子的未来。这显然不是他们最近从美国政府那里听到的消息。领事馆召集了这个小组，解释说：好吧，这是针对如果你们被拘留和驱逐出境该如何计划。比如，如果你被带走了，你的孩子会怎样？你该如何为此做准备？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
A lawyer explains how to sign over the power of attorney to somebody to take care of your kids. Or how to make somebody their temporary guardian. Another speaker explained what to do with your home and bank accounts if you're deported. Yet another-- what if you own a business here in the States? An organizer named Erendira Rendon told the crowd that if immigration shows up at their door, don't let them in unless they have a signed and dated judge's warrant. Usually they don't. And she made the crowd practice in English what to say through the door.
一位律师解释了如何将监护权签署给他人来照看孩子，或者如何指定临时监护人。另一位演讲者解释了如果被驱逐出境，该如何处理房产和银行账户。还有一位讲的是——如果你在美国经营生意该怎么办？一位名叫埃伦迪拉·伦登的组织者告诉大家，如果移民局出现在门口，除非他们有签名并标注日期的法官搜查令，否则不要让他们进来。通常他们没有。她还让大家用英语练习隔着门该说什么。
OK, practica. I do not consent to your entry.
好的，练习一下。我不同意你们进入。
I do not consent to your entry.
我不同意你们进入。
I do not consent to your search of these premises.
我不同意你们搜查这些房屋。
I do not consent to the search of these promises.
The little girl sitting near me said that last one as, "I do not consent to your search of these promises."
坐在我附近的一个小女孩把最后一句说成了：“我不同意你们搜查这些承诺。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
I know it's hard, the speaker says, and that's why you have this. She holds up a packet everybody got. One page has all these same messages in English in big letters. She tells them that if immigration shows up, hold this page against the window. Don't put it up right when you get home today, she says.
演讲者说，我知道这很难，所以你们有这个。她举起每个人都拿到的小册子。其中一页用大号英文字母写着同样的讯息。她告诉他们，如果移民局出现，就把这一页贴在窗户上。她说，今天回家后先别贴出来。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Just put it on the fridge, or leave it by the door. After nearly three hours of presenters and Q&A, one of the last stragglers in the room was one of the moms, Cuca. She talked to one of our producers, Lilly Sullivan. Cuca says it's been hard watching how the possibility of deportation has affected her kids. She has two daughters. The older one is one of the DREAMer kids, covered by DACA, the Deferred Action for Childhood Arrivals, so presumably, she's safe for now. But that could change. She's 19 and a sophomore on a full scholarship at a prestigious college they asked us not to name here. The younger one is a citizen, born here, just 11.
把它贴在冰箱上，或者留在门口就行。经过近三个小时的演讲和问答，房间里最后的滞留者之一是一位母亲，库卡。她和我们的制作人莉莉·沙利文谈了话。库卡说，看着驱逐出境的可能性如何影响她的孩子，这很难过。她有两个女儿。大女儿是“梦想者”的一员，受DACA（童年入境暂缓遣返计划）保护，所以推测她目前是安全的。但这可能会变。她19岁，在一家我们被要求隐去名字的著名大学拿全额奖学金读大二。小女儿是美国公民，在这里出生，才11岁。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
And I've explained to her what could happen.
我已经向她解释过可能会发生什么。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
And she asks, what am I going to do?
她问我，那我该怎么办？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
And I tell her, you go with me. I won't leave you.
我告诉她，你和我一起走。我不会留下你的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
I won't leave you anywhere. You're my daughter, and you go with your mom.
我哪儿也不会丢下你。你是我的女儿，你要跟妈妈一起走。
That's Lilly translating. Cuca recorded the workshop to play for her husband later to help them plan. The family sat down and mapped out a few different scenarios.
那是莉莉在翻译。库卡录下了研讨会的内容，以便以后放给丈夫听，帮助他们制定计划。全家人坐下来，列出了几种不同的方案。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
What happens if they deport one of us? What does the other one do?
如果我们中有一个人被驱逐了怎么办？另一个人该怎么做？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
We've talked to our daughters, and they know the plan.
我们已经和女儿们谈过了，她们知道这个计划。
I think it was my mom who called my sister and I to the living room.
我想是我妈妈把我和姐姐叫到客厅的。
We talked to Whitney, Cuca's older daughter, at their apartment.
我们在公寓里采访了库卡的大女儿惠特尼。
She said, OK, we need to talk. We had to figure out and agree on if somebody gets deported, who will go back with them and who will stay.
她说，好了，我们需要谈谈。我们必须弄清楚并达成一致，如果有人被驱逐，谁会跟他们回去，谁会留下来。
In their first conversation, they all decided that, if one of them was sent to Mexico, all four of them would go. But then later, Whitney's mom, Cuca, started thinking, you know, maybe Whitney should stay in America, finish college. So that became the plan. The other three would go. And then Cuca realized, oh, to set up a life in Mexico, they're going to need a lot of money. So she began to wonder, if she were deported, was it a good idea for Whitney's dad to leave with her and give up his American income?
在最初的谈话中，他们都决定，如果其中一人被遣返回墨西哥，他们四个人都会走。但后来，惠特尼的母亲库卡开始想，也许惠特尼应该留在美国完成大学学业。于是方案就变成了那样，另外三人走。后来库卡意识到，哦，要在墨西哥重新生活，他们需要很多钱。所以她开始担心，如果她被驱逐了，惠特尼的爸爸和她一起走，放弃他的美国收入，这主意好吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
So I said no. It can't be that, if I go back, he goes back. He has to wait and get some money together--
所以我说不，不能那样，如果我回去，他也要回去。他必须留下来存点钱——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
--to at least get a bed and light and gas. Basic things that we need to live.
——至少要买张床、弄到电和煤气。那是我们生活的基本必需品。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
And in the situation where he's deported--
而在他被驱逐的情况下——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
Jeez. It gets really complicated, you know?
天哪。这真的非常复杂，你知道吗？
For me personally, it was devastating to have to have that kind of conversation and process the fact that we were having that conversation.
对我个人而言，不得不进行那样的对话，并消化我们正在进行这种对话的事实，是毁灭性的。
Seems like it was even harder for her little sister, Naomi, the 11-year-old, who kind of zones out in video games or just cracks jokes whenever the family starts talking about this stuff. The reality of having to relocate to Mexico, a country she's never set foot in?
这对她11岁的小妹妹内奥米来说似乎更难。每当家人开始谈论这些事情时，她就会沉浸在电子游戏中或开玩笑。不得不搬到墨西哥——一个她从未踏足过的国家——这到底意味着什么？
Hoo, boy, was I freaked out because I thought that I couldn't take anything over there. Yeah, so at first I was worried about not having any snacks, not having any computers, not having any LEGOs, not having anything fun. So yeah. Some of those LEGOs, they don't even make anymore, like the SpongeBob LEGOs. I'm a big fan of SpongeBob. So yeah, that was the part that I was mostly freaked out about. Yeah. And school. I mean, would I continue? Yeah.
天哪，我当时吓坏了，因为我想我什么都不能带过去。起初我担心没有零食，没有电脑，没有乐高，没有有趣的东西。所以，是的。有些乐高积木，比如海绵宝宝的，他们甚至不再生产了。我是海绵宝宝的超级粉丝。所以，是的，那是我最担心的事情。还有学校。我的意思是，我还能继续上学吗？是的。
She said actually she could barely remember anything anyone said in these family discussions about their plans. Couldn't remember how she felt. When her mom prodded her a little, she's said--
她说其实她几乎记不清在这些家庭讨论中任何人说过的话了。记不起自己的感受。当她妈妈稍微追问她时，她说——
Ehh, [INAUDIBLE], yeah, OK, so my dad was serious. And like, I don't know. My mom also-- yeah. I think I'm starting to remember now. Some of us actually were crying. Yeah. Yeah, and I'm just thinking about stuff, like is there going to be a snow day? And I'm praying to God, please be a snow day.
呃，[听不清]，是的，好吧，我爸爸是认真的。我也……我不知道。我妈妈也——是的。我想我开始想起来了。我们中有些人真的哭了。是的。我在想一些事情，比如会不会有暴风雪停课日？我在祈祷上帝，请一定要有暴风雪停课日。
She means like the next day in Chicago. That's what she was thinking about during this tense family sit-down. And this is pretty much how she talked about her feelings with us until Lilly started asking about this one conversation that Naomi had with her mom, just the two of them talking about being deported.
她是说在芝加哥的第二天。这就是她在紧张的家庭谈话中在想的事情。这就是她和我们谈论感受的方式，直到莉莉开始问及内奥米和她妈妈的一次对话，只有她们两人谈论关于被驱逐出境的事。
Then I heard about the plans, which I kind of feel now worried. What would happen to my sister? Yeah. So that's something that I worry about.
后来我听说了这些计划，我现在感到很担心。我姐姐会怎样？是的。所以这就是我担心的事。
You worry about what would happen to your sister? What do you worry about?
你担心你姐姐会发生什么？你担心什么？
[CRYING]
[哭泣]
I wouldn't see her for like two years or more. We're-- we're a fam-- we're a family. I want to stay together, not be separated. [CRYING]
我有两年或更久见不到她了。我们是……我们是一家人。我想在一起，不想分开。[哭泣]
Yeah, that's-- that's the part that right now I'm worrying most about. Yeah.
是的，那……那是我现在最担心的部分。是的。
For now, the family is preparing just in case. Getting the last few official documents in hand, getting Naomi Mexican citizenship in addition to her American citizenship, so it'll be easier to move her to Mexico, if needs be. And they have this system that, when one of them leaves the house, when they get to where they're going, they call to say that they safely got there. Cuca worries most about her husband. He goes to work in the suburbs.
目前，这家人正在做万全准备。准备好最后几份正式文件，除了美国公民身份外，还给内奥米办理了墨西哥公民身份，以便在必要时更容易搬到墨西哥。他们建立了一个系统，当其中一人离家时，到达目的地后会打电话报平安。库卡最担心她的丈夫，他去郊区上班。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
When the phone rings and I see his number, I'm like, oh, OK. He arrived.
当电话响了，看到是他的号码，我就想，哦，好的。他到了。
For all these things the family is doing to prepare for the worst, the truth is, it's still not clear how much danger they're actually in. It's still not clear how aggressively the Trump administration is going to be deporting people under the new rules that they've just adopted. So much is still in the air.
尽管这家人为了防患于未然做了这么多准备，事实是，他们到底面临多大的危险仍不清楚。特朗普政府在新颁布的规则下会以多大力度遣返人员，目前还不清楚。很多事情仍然悬而未决。
And one place you can see that is this hotline that a church set up in West Chicago, the Faith, Life, and Hope Mission. Erica Velasquez is one of the volunteers who answers calls-- on her personal cell phone, by the way. She told me she's getting 60 to 70 a day, and that it's driving her husband nuts. Some questions that she gets are totally random. One green card holder, who's in the process of becoming a citizen, wondered if having a tattoo could endanger his chances.
你可以从西芝加哥一个教会设立的热线电话中看出这一点，即信仰、生活与希望使命团。埃里卡·贝拉斯克斯是接听电话的志愿者之一——顺便说一句，是用她的个人手机。她告诉我，她每天接到60到70个电话，这让她丈夫快疯了。有些问题非常随机。一位正在入籍过程中的绿卡持有者想知道，有纹身是否会危及他的机会。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
And they ask me, Erica, I heard that now, if you have a tattoo, they're going to interpret that as if I'm a criminal or like I'm in some kind of gang. So am I not going to be able to work it out?
他们问我，埃里卡，我听说现在如果你有纹身，他们会把你解读为罪犯，或者认为你是帮派成员。所以我还能办成吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
It surprised me. I didn't know what to say.
这让我很吃惊。我不知道该说什么。
People call, asking about the food stamps. The new guidelines say you can get prioritized for deportation if you receive government benefits you shouldn't have. So if the parents are not citizens but the kids are citizens, can they argue that the kids are the ones getting the food stamps? Are they OK?
人们打电话询问食品券的事。新方针称，如果你领取了本不该领取的政府福利，你可能会被优先驱逐。那么，如果父母不是公民但孩子是公民，他们可以辩称是孩子在领食品券吗？他们安全吗？
The guidelines also say you can get prioritized for removal if you committed or just been charged with any crimes at all. And people call asking about what they thought of as minor offenses on their records-- traffic tickets, DUIs-- would they now be prioritized for removal?
指导方针还称，如果你犯下任何罪行或仅被指控有任何罪行，你都可能被优先驱逐。人们打电话询问他们记录中认为轻微的违法行为——交通罚单、酒驾——现在会被优先驱逐吗？
I talked to one of the lawyers who spoke at the consulate, Salvador Cicero. He's a green card holder himself. He says one of the new guidelines he finds most chilling is the one that says to prioritize for removal anyone who quote, "in the judgment of an immigration officer poses a risk to public safety or national security."
我和曾在领事馆发言的律师萨尔瓦多·西塞罗谈过。他自己也是绿卡持有者。他说他发现最令人生畏的一条新指南是，将任何“在移民官员判断下对公共安全或国家安全构成风险的人”列为优先遣返对象。
Yeah, that is the scariest thing, I think. If, in his discretion, you pose a threat to public safety. What does that mean? Does that mean that if I am loitering, you are a threat to public safety. You're out. I mean, how wide is that power? It's incredibly vague, and that is a problem. I mean, as it reads, it hasn't been further defined as of yet.
是的，我认为那是最可怕的事情。如果根据他的判断，你对公共安全构成威胁，那是什么意思？这意味着如果我在游荡，我就是对公共安全构成威胁？你被驱逐了。我的意思是，那项权力有多大？它极其模糊，这是一个问题。我的意思是，按照文本的解读，目前还没有进一步定义。
So for the moment, green card holders, undocumented immigrants-- nobody knows what to expect. And that uncertainty has led to a lot of fear. Cuca's husband, Ignacio, told me he's become paranoid. He'll see a truck with weird lights on the highway and worry that it's immigration.
所以目前，绿卡持有者、无证移民——没人知道会发生什么。这种不确定性导致了巨大的恐惧。库卡的丈夫伊格纳西奥告诉我，他变得疑神疑鬼。他看到高速公路上有奇怪灯光的卡车，就会担心是移民局。
Well, today on our show, we have a program about rules and what happens when they're vague and randomly enforced and you can't predict what's going to happen to you-- even if you're in a tropical paradise. That's the first half of the show. We're going to Hawaii. In the second half of the show, we have the rules in a very different sort of paradise. We're talking about the New Jersey suburbs.
今天我们的节目有一个关于规则的专题，以及当规则模糊不清、随机执行，以至于你无法预测自己会遭遇什么时会发生什么——即使你身处热带天堂。这是节目的前半部分。我们要去夏威夷。在节目的后半部分，我们要讲在另一种截然不同的天堂里的规则。我们谈的是新泽西州的郊区。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, That's Just How I Rule.
第一幕，这就是我的规矩。
I remember once visiting Hawaii and hearing about this island that, as outsiders and as white people, we were not allowed to go to. It was just for native Hawaiians, I remember being told. People sometimes call it the Forbidden Island. It's real name is Niihau. And even if you're from Hawaii, apparently it's a mysterious place.
我还记得曾经访问夏威夷，听说了这个岛。当时人们告诉我们，作为外来者和白人，我们是不允许去的。我记得有人告诉我，那只是为夏威夷原住民准备的。人们有时称它为“禁岛”。它的真名叫尼豪岛。即使你是夏威夷本地人，显然那也是个神秘的地方。
I pretty much knew nothing about Niihau.
我几乎对尼豪岛一无所知。
This is Adia White, a public radio reporter who grew up on Maui.
这是阿迪亚·怀特，一名在茂宜岛长大的公共广播记者。
In school, we learned a lot about all of the other islands. A little bit about that history. But for Niihau, they pretty much told us nothing.
在学校里，我们学习了很多关于其他岛屿的知识。一点历史。但对于尼豪岛，他们几乎什么都没告诉我们。
[HAWAIIAN MUSIC PLAYING]
[夏威夷音乐]
The little I knew about it was that it's a piece of the original Hawaii. That's what everyone kind of thought about it, right? Like on Niihau people live as they did before Hawaii was colonized. It's what it's supposed to be like.
我所知道的一点是，它是原始夏威夷的一部分。大家都是这么想的，对吧？就像尼豪岛上的人们生活得和夏威夷被殖民之前一样。它本该就是那样的。
So for instance, it predates the kind of Hawaiian music that you're hearing right now. You can see Niihau on a map. It's to the west of Kauai. About 70 square miles or so. A lot smaller than Maui or Oahu or anyplace in Hawaii you normally hear about.
所以，举个例子，它比你现在听到的这种夏威夷音乐还要早。你可以在地图上看到尼豪岛。它在考艾岛的西面。大约70平方英里。比茂宜岛、欧胡岛或你通常听说的任何夏威夷岛屿都要小得多。
Growing up, Adia didn't know what to picture it was like there. But she figured--
成长过程中，阿迪亚不知道那里是什么样子。但她认为——
Like an original-- a traditional Hawaiian village where it was governed by native Hawaiians. They decided who could come and who could go. They decided who they wanted to invite and how they wanted to live.
像一个原始的、传统的夏威夷村庄，由夏威夷原住民管理。他们决定谁能来，谁能走。他们决定想邀请谁，想怎么生活。
So about a year ago, she started looking into what happens on Niihau. And she learned that it is not that at all. It's basically a family of white people who own everything and run the place even though they don't live there. They set the rules, which seem to be unwritten. And some of the rules are administered in an unpredictable sort of ad hoc way.
所以大约一年前，她开始调查尼豪岛上发生了什么。她了解到那根本不是那么回事。基本上是一个白人家庭拥有那里的一切，并管理这个地方，尽管他们并不住在那里。他们制定了规则，这些规则似乎是不成文的。而且有些规则是以一种不可预测的临时方式实施的。
One of our producers, Sean Cole, joined Adia in reporting the story this fall. You can't just go to Niihau and interview the islanders. And even the ones who leave Niihau and move to the other Hawaiian Islands, they're pretty tight-lipped about life there. But Sean and Adia found a handful of people who were willing to talk to them. Here's what they learned.
我们的制作人之一肖恩·科尔今年秋天和阿迪亚一起报道了这个故事。你不能随便去尼豪岛采访岛民。即使是那些离开尼豪岛搬到其他夏威夷岛屿的人，对那里的生活也守口如瓶。但肖恩和阿迪亚找到了一些愿意与他们交谈的人。这就是他们所了解到的。
How Niihau got this way isn't a secret at all. Basically, back in the 1860s, when Hawaii was still a kingdom, the king sold the island to a white family for $10,000 in gold. They wanted to ranch cattle on it. And there was a community of about a thousand native Hawaiians living there. According to the family, before the ink was even dry on the contract handing over the land, the king looked at them and said, the day may come when Hawaiians are not as strong in Hawaii as they are now. And if that day comes, please do what you can to help them.
尼豪岛怎么会变成这样一点也不神秘。基本上，19世纪60年代，当夏威夷还是一个王国时，国王以1万美元的黄金将该岛卖给了一个白人家庭。他们想在那儿放牧牛群。当时那里住着大约一千名夏威夷原住民。据该家庭称，在转让土地合同的墨迹还没干之前，国王看着他们说，夏威夷人可能会在夏威夷变得不如现在强大。如果那一天真的到来，请尽你们所能去帮助他们。
That day, of course, did come, and the family has tried to keep their promise to the king all these years. And the way they interpreted helping the villagers was, let's preserve this place to be just as it was in 1864 when we bought it. So this is the last place on Earth where the language everybody uses every day is Hawaiian. They learn it as their first language and they speak an older form of Hawaiian than you hear anywhere else. Also, the lifestyle there is pretty spartan.
那一天当然到来了，那个家族这些年来一直努力履行对国王的承诺。他们理解的帮助村民的方式是：让我们保护这个地方，让它保持在1864年我们买下它时的样子。所以这是地球上最后一个人们每天都在使用夏威夷语的地方。他们将夏威夷语作为第一语言学习，并且说的是比你在其他任何地方听到的更古老的夏威夷语。此外，那里的生活方式非常简朴。
No running water, no electricity, no bathrooms. So it's outhouses that we use, yeah.
没有自来水，没有电，没有厕所。所以我们用的是室外厕所。
This is Tuti Sanborn. She lives on Oahu now, but her family's from Niihau and she lived there every summer as a kid. She's the kind of person who uses phrases like "feel the aloha" in earnest and gets away with it.
这是图蒂·桑伯恩。她现在住在欧胡岛，但她的家人来自尼豪岛，她小时候每年夏天都住在那里。她是那种会真诚地使用“感受阿罗哈精神”这种短语且让人听着顺耳的人。
So as the evening approached, we'd gather all of the lanterns and refuel them with kerosene. I remember my mom's kitchen. There was a kerosene stove in it. I remember doing that kind of stuff. I remember going to the wells to gather water.
所以随着傍晚临近，我们会收集所有的灯笼，用煤油重新加满。我记得我妈妈的厨房。里面有一个煤油炉。我记得做过这类事。我记得去井边打水。
Tuti and the other Niihauans we talked to all described the same thing. No paved roads, no streetlights, one-floor houses with tin roofs, big yards, horses in the yards, peacocks and wild turkeys and pigs roaming around. And they fish and hunt for their food a lot of the time.
图蒂和其他我们采访的尼豪岛人都描述了同样的事情。没有铺设的道路，没有路灯，带锡屋顶的平房，大院子，院子里有马，孔雀、野生火鸡和猪在四处漫步。他们大部分时间都在捕鱼和狩猎以获取食物。
There's a church in the center of the village, and a kind of meeting hall. A little school. But no stores or anything. In fact, no one uses money on Niihau. There's no formal medical care there, either. No law enforcement. The pastor of the church settles any disputes that flare up.
村中心有一座教堂，还有一个集会厅。一所小学校。但没有商店之类的。事实上，尼豪岛上没有人使用现金。那里也没有正式的医疗护理。没有执法机构。教堂的牧师负责解决任何爆发的纠纷。
These days, they have solar panels to charge their phones and iPads and a few trucks to drive around the island. But mostly it's Hawaii circa 1864. Christian missionaries had been in the islands for decades by then. People told us that church attendance on Niihau is mandatory. Also, the family that owns Niihau, the Robinsons, are famous abstainers from all vice, and they've always required the residents of the island to live by those same values.
如今，他们有太阳能电池板给手机和iPad充电，还有几辆卡车在岛上行驶。但大部分时间还是1864年左右的夏威夷。那时基督教传教士已经在岛上待了几十年。人们告诉我们，在尼豪岛参加礼拜是强制性的。此外，拥有尼豪岛的鲁滨逊家族以戒除所有恶习而闻名，他们一直要求岛上的居民遵循同样的价值观。
No alcohol is allowed. No smoking.
严禁饮酒。严禁吸烟。
No drugs. No guns. And if you're caught, say, drinking or doing drugs, you can get kicked off the island, which feels like a weird phrase to be saying out loud about real people.
没有毒品。没有枪支。如果你被发现喝酒或吸毒，你可能会被赶出岛屿，这对于描述真实的人来说听起来像是一个很奇怪的短语。
The Robinsons insist that they're simply protecting the villagers from all the awfulness of the modern world, just like they promised the king. The oldest members of the Robinson family are Keith and Bruce. They're brothers, both in their 70s. There was a documentary made about Keith in 2005 called Robinson Crusader, about his work to preserve endangered plant species. And he talks a little about Niihau in it.
鲁滨逊家族坚称，他们只是像承诺国王的那样，保护村民免受现代世界所有丑恶的影响。鲁滨逊家族最年长的成员是基思和布鲁斯。他们是兄弟，都70多岁了。2005年曾拍摄过一部关于基思的纪录片《鲁滨逊十字军》，讲述他致力于保护濒危植物的工作。他在片中也谈到了尼豪岛。
I haven't seen any aircraft crashing into skyscrapers here. I haven't seen any plagues of AIDS here. As far as I know, there isn't one case of AIDS on the island. We have no drug problem. If there is any kind of a social problem here, the elders of the village sort it out by themselves. And if they can't handle it, they come to us.
我在这里没见过飞机撞向摩天大楼。我没见过这里有艾滋病瘟疫。据我所知，岛上没有一例艾滋病。我们没有毒品问题。如果这里有什么社会问题，村民长辈会自己解决。如果他们处理不了，就会来找我们。
If this sounds like an oddly colonialist sort of project to have lasted into the 21st century, with white people setting the rules for native Hawaiians, I want to be clear. The villagers on Niihau are American citizens. They just happen to live on an island that's privately owned by this family. They can move away anytime they want. But if they want to stay, they have to respect the rules, that this is a regulated paradise. And people do want to stay. Everyone we spoke to who lived there, including people who have plenty of criticisms of the Robinsons, they all said they loved it.
如果这听起来像是一个奇怪的殖民主义项目在21世纪依然存在，由白人为夏威夷原住民制定规则，我想说明一点。尼豪岛上的村民是美国公民。他们只是恰好住在一个由这个家族私有的岛屿上。他们随时可以离开。但如果他们想留下来，就必须遵守规则，这里是一个受监管的天堂。而且人们确实想留下来。我们采访到的所有住在那里的人，包括那些对鲁滨逊家族有很多批评的人，都说他们热爱那里。
Did everybody really go to church on Sunday or do they try to--
每个人真的都去教堂做礼拜吗，还是他们尝试——
Yes.
是的。
--sneak out of it?
——溜出去？
That was the only, only social event of the island besides parties, if they had parties.
那是岛上除了派对之外唯一的社交活动，如果他们举办派对的话。
What were the parties like? Were they drinking juice?
派对是什么样的？他们在喝果汁吗？
You know, the parties were two weeks long.
你知道，派对持续两周。
What?
什么？
Two weeks-- every day. And on Sunday. And on Sunday. It's an island full of aloha. So they'd have the parties for two weeks. So when they ordered food, they ordered a lot.
两周——每天。还有周日。连周日都有。这是一个充满阿罗哈精神的岛屿。所以他们会开两周派对。所以当他们订购食物时，他们订了很多。
They have canned goods and other foods shipped over from Kauai to supplement the fishing and hunting. Or they go to Kauai and shop themselves sometimes.
他们从考艾岛运送罐头食品和其他食物，作为捕鱼和狩猎的补充。或者他们有时自己去考艾岛购物。
A couple of the rules on Niihau seem a little more arbitrary than the others. Pulani Kahokuloa says his dad was kicked off the island when Pulani was 13, and Pulani left with him. That was 30 years ago. He could go back today, except for one thing.
尼豪岛上的几条规则看起来比其他规则更随意。普拉尼·卡霍库洛阿说，当他13岁时他父亲被赶出了岛，普拉尼和他一起离开了。那是30年前的事了。除了有一件事，他今天可以回去。
I have to cut my hair and shave.
我得剪掉头发，刮胡子。
What?
什么？
(CHUCKLING) Yeah. That's kind of ridiculous.
（轻笑）是的。那有点荒谬。
No beards are allowed on the island. And no long hair on the guys. Pulani's a real ponytail, backwards-ball-cap kind of dude. And his sons have long hair, too. They'd all have to get haircuts if they want to go back.
岛上不允许留胡子。男人们也不允许留长发。普拉尼是个扎马尾辫、戴棒球帽的人。他的儿子们也留着长发。如果他们想回去，都得剪头发。
I don't know what's the reason, because I had uncles that showed me older pictures when they were young. They had like Elvis hair, like whoosh, like long hair.
我不知道原因，因为我叔叔给我看了他们年轻时的老照片。他们留着猫王那样的发型，呼——那种长发。
So it's a new rule.
所以这是个新规矩。
Yeah, it's a new rule. It's a silly rule.
是的，是个新规矩。这是个愚蠢的规矩。
Pulani has a really hard time with the haircut thing. He kept coming back to it during our interview. We'd be talking about the rules in general and his distaste for them, and then he'd say something like this.
普拉尼对剪头发的事感到非常困扰。在采访中他不断提到这一点。我们讨论一般规则和他对规则的厌恶时，他会说这样的话。
Especially the silly one of cutting hair. That one. That's the mean one that blows everybody's mind away when they ask me, how come you cannot go back to Niihau [INAUDIBLE]? Oh, he's got to cut his hair. What? No way. Hawaiians had long hair back in the days. We looked like cavemen. I'd say, yeah. Well, not today. You gotta cut the hair.
尤其是剪头发那个愚蠢的规则。那个。那是当别人问我为什么不能回尼豪岛时，最让人震惊的卑鄙规则。哦，他得剪头发。什么？不可能。夏威夷人以前留长发。我们看起来像穴居人。我会说，是的，但不是现在。你得剪头发。
It really bothers you.
这真的让你很困扰。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It does.
是的。
And there's a rule that Tuti Sanborn violated. It's a little more nuanced.
还有一条规则是图蒂·桑伯恩违反的。情况稍微细微一些。
[SPEAKING HAWAIIAN]
[讲夏威夷语]
She wanted to document what life was like on the island. She was worried those traditions would be forgotten. So she writes about the island sometimes. And she did a series of TV interviews with her family, asking them what they remembered. Just innocuous stuff.
她想记录岛上的生活是什么样的。她担心那些传统会被遗忘。所以她有时会写关于岛屿的文章。她还与家人进行了一系列电视采访，问他们记得什么。只是一些无伤大雅的东西。
I did one with my dad on saddle making.
我和我爸爸做过一次关于马鞍制作的采访。
[SPEAKING HAWAIIAN]
[讲夏威夷语]
I did one with my sister. I did a few.
我和我姐姐做过一次。我做过几次。
In a way, she was doing the same thing the Robinsons were doing-- trying to preserve native Hawaiianness. Capture it in video amber. But the Robinsons didn't see it that way, and now she's not allowed back on the island. To them, the interviews, the articles, all of that violated what you could call the first rule of Niihau. You do not talk about Niihau.
在某种程度上，她所做的事和鲁滨逊家族正在做的事一样——试图保护夏威夷原住民文化。用视频把它们像琥珀一样封存。但鲁滨逊家族不这么看，现在她被禁止回岛了。对他们来说，那些采访、文章，所有这些都违反了尼豪岛的第一条规则：不要谈论尼豪岛。
This punishment-- barring some people from the island, even people who left by choice-- this was the thing the Niihauans we talked to were the most bitter about. Tuti's sister, Doreen-- everybody calls her Auntie Deer-- has been barred from moving back to Niihau because she spent too much time away. She lived on the island until she was about 30, but then she moved to Kauai to take care of her mom, who had a stroke.
这种惩罚——禁止某些人回岛，即使是那些主动离开的人——这是我们交谈过的尼豪岛人最愤恨的事情。图蒂的姐姐多琳——大家叫她多琳阿姨——一直被禁止搬回尼豪岛，因为她离开太久了。她在岛上住到大约30岁，但后来搬到考艾岛照顾中风的母亲。
After her parents died, she wanted to move back, but she couldn't, she says, because of Leiana. Leiana is a matriarch of the Robinson family, and she's the one you have to call when you want to go back to visit or to live full-time again.
父母去世后，她想搬回去，但她说因为蕾亚娜她搬不回去。蕾亚娜是鲁滨逊家族的女家长，当你想要回去探亲或长期居住时，你必须给她打电话。
She said when we come here and stay here like one year or two years, we are considered outsiders. That hurt me. In my heart, it was like-- it was broken. My heart broke. I said, how can she say that? Because I was raised there. When I was born, I was raised there. She said that we belonged here, not there. I broke down, cried, and said, oh, how can that be? Because it's like the island is calling me to go back there.
她说当我们来到这里待了一年或两年，我们就成了外人。那伤害了我。在我的心里，它就像……碎了。我的心碎了。我说，她怎么能这么说？因为我是那里养大的。我出生时，我就是在那儿长大的。她说我们属于这里，不属于那里。我崩溃大哭，说，天哪，怎么会这样？因为感觉岛屿在呼唤我回去。
And it doesn't help that you can see Niihau from Kauai. Driving up and down the road that runs along the ocean, Niihau is a clear mountainous hump just a hop across the water. It feels so reachable, like you could just take a boat there yourself. But of course, you can't. It's private property.
而且从考艾岛能看到尼豪岛，这对缓解心情一点帮助都没有。沿着海岸行驶，尼豪岛是一个清晰的山峰驼背，就在水对面。感觉触手可及，好像你自己坐船就能过去。但当然，你不能。那是私人财产。
The younger of the two Robinson brothers, Bruce Robinson, is considered the main boss of the island. But as he's gotten older, the day-to-day management of Niihau has shifted to his wife, Leiana, which was really exciting for the villagers because Leiana's one of them. She's native Hawaiian. She was actually the daughter of the pastor on Niihau, 30 years or so younger than Bruce. Tuti Sanborn remembers when they got together.
两个鲁滨逊兄弟中较年轻的布鲁斯·鲁滨逊被认为是岛上的主事人。但随着年龄增长，尼豪岛的日常管理转移到了他的妻子蕾亚娜身上，这对村民们来说确实很令人兴奋，因为蕾亚娜是他们中的一员。她是夏威夷原住民。她实际上是尼豪岛上牧师的女儿，比布鲁斯小30岁左右。图蒂·桑伯恩记得他们在一起的时候。
Honestly, I thought, oh, great. Now we have our own that's in a place where she can make changes, and make good changes, and don't have to rule over our people so strictly, yeah? But no. She's just like the Robinsons. She treats the people just like the Robinsons have treated the people.
老实说，我想，噢，太好了。现在我们有自己人在一个可以做出改变的位置，做出好的改变，不必如此严格地统治我们的人民，是吧？但没有。她就像鲁滨逊家族一样。她对待人们的方式和鲁滨逊家族对待人们的方式一模一样。
Which is?
那是？
Strict. I thought it would change, where she would allow me to go. It didn't change at all. It got worse. Yeah.
严格。我原以为会有所改变，她会允许我去。一点也没变。变得更糟了。是的。
Tuti says she's asked Leiana a bunch of times if she can go back to the island. The way it works is that the Robinsons have a military surplus barge, like in Saving Private Ryan-- the kind where the front drops down. They ferry livestock with it, and fuel, and other supplies. And people who want to go back to Niihau can ride over on the barge. Only 20 or 25 people can fit on board. The trip takes a couple of hours. And they run pretty frequently, maybe three times a week. You just have to call and schedule it in advance.
图蒂说她多次问蕾亚娜她能否回岛。运作方式是，鲁滨逊家族有一艘军用剩的驳船，就像《拯救大兵瑞恩》里的那种——前部可以放下的那种。他们用它运输牲畜、燃料和其他物资。想回尼豪岛的人可以搭乘这艘驳船。船上只能容纳20或25人。航程需要几个小时。他们跑得很频繁，可能一周三次。你只需要提前致电并预约。
And I remember calling on one occasion and she just said, oh, sorry, not at the moment. We cannot accommodate you right now. Their usual comment or response is, the barge is full. [LAUGHING]
我还记得有一次我打电话，她只是说，噢，抱歉，现在不行。我们现在无法接待你。他们通常的评语或回应是，船满了。[笑声]
Like of other people going?
就像有其他人要去？
Right.
对。
And things.
还有东西。
Sorry, the barge is full. There's no room. There's no space.
抱歉，船满了。没有空位。没有空间。
You're laughing because that doesn't seem true.
你在笑，因为那似乎不是真的。
Yeah, because I know who goes. We all talk to each other and let each other know.
是的，因为我知道谁去了。我们都互相交谈并通报情况。
How many times did you ask and how often?
你问了多少次，频率如何？
Like three, four years consecutively I tried and was denied. So I just kind of stopped after that. Actually, no. I tried going to someone else. I would ask someone that's influential in my family, can you go ask Leiana that I want to go to Niihau? Still got denied. And I'm like, whatever. You're still my cousin. You cannot change that.
连续三四年我尝试过，但被拒绝了。所以之后我就停止了。其实没有。我试着找别人。我会请在我家中有影响力的人，你可以去问蕾亚娜我想去尼豪岛吗？依然被拒绝。我就想，随便吧。你依然是我的表亲。你改变不了这一点。
This is something we hadn't thought of, but it was so obvious once people pointed it out. On an island this small, everyone's going to be related in some way. So this dynamic between Tuti and Leiana, it's a family dynamic. They're cousins. In fact, people use the word ohana, family, to describe the whole community of Niihauans, both on the island and off.
这是我们没想到的，但一旦人们指出就变得显而易见。在这么小的岛上，每个人都会以某种方式建立亲缘关系。所以图蒂和蕾亚娜之间的这种动态，是一种家庭动态。她们是表姐妹。事实上，人们使用“欧哈纳”（ohana，家庭）这个词来描述整个尼豪岛群体，无论是在岛上还是岛外。
But while Tuti is technically a member of the ohana, Leiana doesn't really consider her that anymore. And there's no court of appeals. No due process. Leiana and the Robinson brothers had the last word.
但虽然图蒂从技术上讲是“欧哈纳”的一员，蕾亚娜并不真的再把她当成那样了。没有上诉法院。没有正当程序。蕾亚娜和鲁滨逊兄弟拥有最终决定权。
Contrary to what Auntie Deer told us, there are people who move away from Niihau to Kauai for a couple of years who are allowed to return, but those folks are more tied into Leiana's inner circle. And as a result, they're really hard to interview. This is an important point. The people that you're hearing from in this story, they're a pretty self-selecting group. They talk to us because they either felt like they had nothing to lose or because they have some sort of issue with how the island is run, if not with Leiana herself.
与多琳阿姨告诉我们的相反，确实有些人搬离尼豪岛去考艾岛几年后被允许返回，但这些人与蕾亚娜的核心圈子联系更紧密。结果，他们很难采访到。这是一个重点。在这个故事中你听到的这些人，是一个自我选择的群体。他们和我们交谈是因为他们要么觉得自己没什么可失去的，要么是因为他们对岛屿的管理方式有某种意见，如果不是针对蕾亚娜本人的话。
With all this policing of who can come and go on the island, and all the people banned from moving back, we wondered how many folks are left living on Niihau. Again, the whole point of this project is to try to preserve a place for native Hawaiians-- their culture and their language.
随着对谁可以来往岛屿的所有警务，以及所有被禁止回岛的人，我们想知道到底还有多少人住在尼豪岛。再说一次，这个项目的全部意义在于尝试为夏威夷原住民保护一个地方——他们的文化和语言。
But even this most basic fact-- the population of Niihau-- was hard to pin down. Right before the Robinson's ancestors bought the island in 1864, again, there were about a thousand people living on Niihau. That's according to the census. And they were worried what was going to happen when the haoles, the white people, took over. In fact, the villagers wrote two letters to the Hawaiian government begging to buy or lease the island themselves, but nobody listened to them. Over the next four years, 700 people moved off of Niihau.
但即使是这个最基本的事实——尼豪岛的人口——也很难确定。在鲁滨逊的祖先1864年买下该岛之前，同样，尼豪岛上有大约一千人居住。那是根据人口普查。他们担心当“haoles”（白人）接管时会发生什么。事实上，村民们写了两封信给夏威夷政府，恳求自己购买或租用该岛，但没人听他们的。在接下来的四年里，700人搬离了尼豪岛。
The latest census from 2010 says there are 170 residents on Niihau. But Pulani Kahokuloa told us the community has really dwindled since then.
2010年的最新人口普查称尼豪岛有170名居民。但普拉尼·卡霍库洛阿告诉我们，自那以后社区真的缩减了。
Let's just see. Right now there is 1, 2, 3-- at least five families are left on Niihau.
让我们看看。现在有1、2、3……尼豪岛至少还剩下五个家庭。
So how many people is that?
那是多少人？
About 21, 25 people?
大约21、25人？
Wait, what? There's only 25 people left on Niihau?
等等，什么？尼豪岛只剩下25个人了吗？
Yep. Just about. But you can try and confirm it with Leiana first. She might give you another different number.
是的。差不多。但你可以先试着和蕾亚娜确认一下。她可能会给你另一个不同的数字。
I should say, by this point we had already started trying to get a hold of Leiana. I left a voicemail at her office. And then a retired reporter I got in touch with on Kauai told her we were working on this story, so I left a second voicemail. In any case, we've asked several people how many villagers are left on the island of Niihau and the range that keeps coming up is between 35 and 50.
我应该说，到这个时候我们已经开始设法联系蕾亚娜了。我在她的办公室留了语音留言。然后我在考艾岛联系到的一位退休记者告诉她我们正在做这个故事，所以我留了第二次语音留言。无论如何，我们问过几个人尼豪岛上还剩下多少村民，反复出现的范围是在35到50之间。
Even a grocery store clerk on Kauai who grew up on Niihau said there's almost nobody left there. He wouldn't go on tape, but when we told him what we were doing, he said, does this mean people will get to go back now? Is that what the story's about?
甚至考艾岛上一位在尼豪岛长大的杂货店店员也说那里几乎没有人了。他拒绝录音，但当我们告诉他我们在做什么时，他说，这是否意味着人们现在可以回去了？这就是故事的内容吗？
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
This is Ira Glass, This American Life. Leave a message. [BEEP]
这是艾拉·格拉斯，《美国生活》。请留言。[嘟声]
Hi, Ira. It's Sean. Contrary to popular belief, there is cell service on Niihau. I am on Niihau. I'm standing on just the wildest beach that I've ever been to. By wild I mean kind of like wilderness. It's like this weird, untamed beach with these lava outcroppings in it. And the water is this unreal multicolored organism. It's just fantastic here. So I thought I should call you from Niihau. And I'll see you soon. All right, bye.
嗨，艾拉。我是肖恩。与普遍的看法相反，尼豪岛上有手机信号。我在尼豪岛。我站在我见过的最荒野的海滩上。我所说的荒野是指某种像荒野一样。这就像这种奇怪、未经驯服的海滩，里面有熔岩露头。海水是一种虚幻的五彩缤纷的有机体。这里简直太棒了。所以我想我应该从尼豪岛给你打电话。我很快就会见到你。好的，再见。
Adia!
阿迪亚！
There is one way outsiders can set foot on Niihau.
外来者踏足尼豪岛有一种方式。
Oop. Animal poop. Just like everywhere.
噢。动物粪便。到处都是。
Back in the '80s, the Robinsons bought a helicopter partly so they could respond to medical emergencies on the island. And to offset the cost of it, they started offering tourist trips to Niihau. Not to the village. You still really can't get anywhere near the village. But anyone with $440, who's not afraid to ride in a helicopter, can take this half-day tour where you soar above the island and then land for a few hours on its northernmost beach.
早在80年代，鲁滨逊一家买了一架直升机，部分是为了让他们能够应对岛上的医疗紧急情况。为了抵消费用，他们开始提供到尼豪岛的旅游行程。不是去村庄。你依然真的无法靠近村庄。但任何有440美元、不害怕坐直升机的人，都可以参加这个半日游，在岛屿上方翱翔，然后降落在其最北端的海滩上几个小时。
It's a beach the villagers use themselves, though they stay away when tourists are around. So there were no people. Not a single building in sight except this one weather-beaten pavilion with a storage hut across from it. So miles of empty beach. And then, behind us, this baking landscape that is not beach, but red dirt, also vast, dotted with scrubby brush and dry grasses. It was like a piece of a foreign planet had fallen into the middle of the Pacific. Adia and I agreed it was unlike any place either of us had ever seen. It was kind of like we had discovered an island.
这是村民自己使用的海滩，尽管游客在场时他们会避开。所以没有人在那儿。视野内没有一栋建筑，除了这个被天气侵蚀的凉亭和对面的储藏小屋。所以是几英里空旷的海滩。然后，在我们身后，这个炙热的景观不是海滩，而是红土，同样广阔，点缀着灌木和干草。它就像一块外星球的碎片掉进了太平洋中部。阿迪亚和我一致认为它不像我们见过的任何地方。感觉就像我们发现了一个岛屿。
On the flight over, the helicopter pilot acted as a tour guide, pointing out sights, talking about the wildlife on the island. He told us that Niihau had been deemed by some the quietest place in the world. Although, as he pointed out, it's not clear how they measure those things.
在飞过来的途中，直升机飞行员充当导游，指出景点，谈论岛上的野生动物。他告诉我们，尼豪岛被一些人认为是世界上最安静的地方。尽管正如他指出的那样，尚不清楚他们是如何衡量这些东西的。
I wouldn't call this the quietest place in the world at all.
我根本不会称这里为世界上最安静的地方。
It's not quiet.
它并不安静。
It's really loud here.
这里非常吵。
It's very loud here.
We spent four hours roaming around on the beach, which didn't give us any more understanding of what life was like there. So here's some other stuff we learned.
我们在海滩上漫步了四个小时，这并没有让我们对那里的生活有更多了解。所以这是我们了解到的其他一些事情。
First and foremost, it's been hard for the Robinsons to keep this place going. The ranching business is mostly unprofitable. They've tried other sources of revenue-- making honey, manufacturing charcoal, neither of which worked. They also run hunting safaris, where people pay to shoot the wild pigs and other game. And there are the helicopter tours, of course. But really, the most stable source of income on the island thus far is one that won't sound traditional, nor Hawaiian. Military contracts.
首先，鲁滨逊家族很难维持这个地方的运转。牧场生意大多是不盈利的。他们尝试过其他收入来源——制作蜂蜜、生产木炭，都没有成功。他们还经营狩猎旅行，人们付钱去射杀野猪和其他猎物。当然还有直升机旅游。但说实话，迄今为止岛上最稳定的收入来源听起来并不传统，也不夏威夷。军事合同。
There's a Navy radar facility on the island, and a recent contract provides for 19 full-time-equivalent jobs. Also, various Navy exercises have been carried out on the island. The Robinsons seem to be proud of their contracts with the military. Keith, the older brother, talked with the villagers about working with the Navy at a public hearing that was held on Niihau back in 2015.
岛上有一个海军雷达设施，最近的一份合同提供了19个全职同等职位。此外，各种海军演习已经在岛上进行。鲁滨逊家族似乎对他们与军方的合同感到自豪。年长的兄弟基思在2015年尼豪岛举行的公开听证会上与村民谈论了与海军合作的事。
Without that money, frankly, your community, your jobs would not have survived. It's just that simple. For the time being, US Navy is your source of income that keeps all of you going here and which keeps us going and allows us to pay the taxes on this place.
坦白说，没有那笔钱，你们的社区，你们的工作就不会存活下来。就这么简单。目前，美国海军是你们的收入来源，维持着你们这里的一切，也维持着我们，并使我们能够支付这个地方的税收。
The villagers are paid to maintain the radar facility-- and the ranch, for that matter. They live rent-free. We heard that some receive food stamps and other public benefits. As to the question of whether military contracts are compatible with the mission of preserving native Hawaiianness, Keith has said, it's a lot more compatible than tourism. The military is stealth, he said, and it doesn't leave litter behind.
村民们得到报酬来维护雷达设施——以及牧场。他们免房租。我们听说有些人领取食品券和其他公共福利。至于军事合同是否与保护夏威夷原住民文化的使命相符的问题，基思曾说，这比旅游业要相符得多。军方是隐身的，他说，而且不会留下垃圾。
We tried a couple more times to reach Leiana to get her take on everything we'd heard, and it started to seem like a dead end. And then on our last full day on Kauai, a little before 9:00 AM, my phone rang. It was her.
我们又尝试了几次联系蕾亚娜以获取她对我们所听到的所有事情的看法，但这开始看起来像是死胡同。然后在考艾岛的最后一个完整日，上午9点前一点点，我的电话响了。是她。
I know what your name is, she said, but I don't know what your mission is. I explained as best I could, but I was nervous. In our minds, Leiana had been built up into this towering intimidator. But finally, she agreed to speak with us. Meet me at the helicopter office in an hour, she said. Somehow, both of our voices became very high when we got there.
“我知道你的名字，”她说，“但我不知道你的任务是什么。”我尽力解释了，但我很紧张。在我们心目中，蕾亚娜已经被塑造成一个高不可攀的恐吓者。但最终，她同意与我们交谈。“一小时后在直升机办公室见我，”她说。不知何故，当我们到达那里时，我们俩的声音都变得非常尖锐。
Hi. Good morning. Aloha. How are you?
嗨。早上好。阿罗哈。你好吗？
Leiana's decidedly not a towering intimidator. She's maybe 5' 4", with long, dark hair, plaid shirt, jeans, and boots. She was very gracious and pleasant with us.
蕾亚娜绝对不是一个高不可攀的恐吓者。她身高大约5英尺4英寸，留着深色长发，穿着格子衬衫、牛仔裤和靴子。她对我们非常亲切和愉快。
Do you want to join us over here?
你想过来加入我们吗？
Sure. Uh--
当然。呃——
But as soon as she saw the microphone, her eyes widened. She said she didn't want to go on tape. So you're not going to hear her voice in this story. She said she tries to stay out of the media, if possible. She doesn't feel like she should be speaking for the whole community.
但当她看到麦克风时，眼睛睁大了。她说她不想录音。所以你不会在这个故事中听到她的声音。她说她尽量不接受媒体采访，如果可能的话。她不觉得她应该代表整个社区说话。
And she clearly doesn't have a lot of time for sit-downs like this. During our visit, her cell phone wouldn't stop ringing-- and the office phone, too. She's the point person for everyone now, she said. But she said she'd try to answer any questions we had. And then she said, you can phrase the answers however you want.
而且她显然没有太多时间进行这种坐谈。在我们访问期间，她的手机一直响个不停——办公室电话也是。她说她现在是所有人的联络人。但她说她会尽量回答我们有的任何问题。然后她说，你可以用任何你想要的方式表达答案。
We told Leiana who else we'd talked to, and as soon as we said the first name, Tuti Sanborn, she did a kind of epic eye roll. Well, Tuti. I mean, she said, but she stopped herself. OK, OK, she said. Who else? Pulani Kahokuloa, I said, and she got tense again. You're all the way over here, she said, gesturing away from herself. She said our story was clearly one-sided. And that's why we came to you, I said.
我们告诉蕾亚娜我们还采访了谁，当我们说到第一个名字图蒂·桑伯恩时，她翻了一个史诗般的白眼。“好吧，图蒂。我的意思是，”她说，但她止住了。“好的，好的，”她说。“还有谁？”我说了普拉尼·卡霍库洛阿，她又紧张起来。“你们都在这边，”她说，做了一个远离自己的手势。她说我们的故事显然是一边倒的。我说，这就是我们来找你的原因。
And so we got into it. Leiana said there is a limit to how long you can be away out of the community and still be let back on Niihau. She can only accommodate so many people, and she has to make choices. She said, I don't know what Tuti's purpose is for going home. She's crossed a lot of lines.
所以我们深入探讨了。蕾亚娜说，离开社区多长时间还可以返回尼豪岛是有期限的。她只能安置那么多人，她必须做出选择。她说，“我不知道图蒂回家的目的是什么。她越过了很多界限。”
What lines, I said. She said, people of the village don't want her being the voice of the people, meaning all the ways that Tuti documents life on Niihau for the rest of the world. And then she gave us this one example that really stuck in her craw that Tuti hadn't mentioned.
“什么界限？”我说。她说，村民们不希望她成为人民的代言人，指的是图蒂向世界其他地方记录尼豪岛生活的所有方式。然后她给了我们一个真正让她如鲠在喉的例子，那是图蒂没有提到的。
She said Tuti had worked as a consultant on an episode of Hawaii Five-O, the new rebooted version that's on TV now. In the episode, a college professor is murdered after sneaking onto Niihau to steal a rare plant. There are aerial shots of Niihau in the show, although the scenes in the actual village looked like they were filmed somewhere else. Tuti herself plays a village elder.
她说图蒂曾担任电视剧《夏威夷五零特警》新重启版本的顾问。在这一集中，一名大学教授在潜入尼豪岛窃取珍稀植物后被谋杀。剧中出现了尼豪岛的航拍镜头，尽管实际村庄的场景看起来像是在其他地方拍摄的。图蒂本人扮演一名村庄长辈。
[SPEAKING HAWAIIAN]
[讲夏威夷语]
Leiana said, it's not her right to be their point person on Niihau, especially a big production like that. They should have come to us. I've worked with Jurassic Park, she said. Which is true. There's a scene in one of the movies of the Robinsons' helicopter flying over one of their properties on Kauai. And so Leiana felt cut out of this one. Why is this any different, she said. Why are we killing each other?
蕾亚娜说，这不是她作为尼豪岛代言人的权利，尤其是像那样的大制作。他们本应该来找我们。我说，我曾与《侏罗纪公园》合作过。这是事实。电影中有一个场景是鲁滨逊家族的直升机飞过他们在考艾岛的一处房产。所以蕾亚娜觉得被排除在了这次合作之外。她说，这有什么不同吗？我们为什么要自相残杀？
We did a little fact-checking on this. For what it's worth, Tuti was not the point person on Niihau for Hawaii Five-O.
我们对此做了一点事实核查。无论如何，图蒂并不是《夏威夷五零特警》在尼豪岛的对接人。
We asked Leiana about the haircut rule-- Pulani's big favorite. She said they don't like tattoos on the island, either, or piercings, or hair dye. All of that stuff has gotten really out of hand, she says. And she says church attendance on Niihau is not mandatory.
我们问了蕾亚娜关于剪发规则的事——普拉尼的最爱。她说岛上也不喜欢纹身，或者穿孔，或者染发。她说所有那些事情已经真正失控了。她说在尼豪岛参加礼拜不是强制性的。
Pulani's complaining caught her off guard, and she refuted him on pretty much every point. She gave a much higher number for how many people are on the island than Pulani did. Not 25. More like 125. And she told us, sometimes it's the community who doesn't want someone to come back on the island, in which case, they'll tell her, and she'll deliver the news. She's fine with being the bad guy, she says.
普拉尼的抱怨让她猝不及防，她几乎在每个点上都反驳了他。她给出的岛上人数比普拉尼给出的高得多。不是25人。更像是125人。她告诉我们，有时是社区不想让某人回岛，在这种情况下，他们会告诉她，她会发布消息。她说她没关系当坏人。
"You interviewed a whole different group than my group," she said. "We may be of the same blood, but they're not with me. I have to listen to the community. If you take a hike, you take a hike. That's all there is to it. They've given their heart elsewhere, so why should I waste my energy for these people that have come to the table to say blah, blah, blah, blah, blah over these people that have dedicated their life to going back to the family? It's a really-- you can put it however you want to."
“你们采访的群体和我带的群体完全不同，”她说。“我们可能流着同样的血，但他们不和我在一起。我必须倾听社区的声音。如果你要走，就走。就是这样。他们已经把心交给了别处，所以我为什么要为这些人浪费精力，这些人来到桌前说些废话，而不是为那些致力于回归家庭的人？这真的……你可以随你怎么写。”
Also, we finally got to talk with someone who is part of that close-knit group of Niihauans Leiana talked about-- Pulani's sister, actually, who also didn't want her voice on the radio. She said, "we like Niihau the way it is. And I believe the Robinsons are keeping it that way. They're really good people. Honestly, if you were the owner of an island but you live on Kauai, would you pay for the fuel for the barge to send people over for free and not charge for each box that they ship to Niihau? That means a lot to us. They really do take care of the people. I can't believe you guys came all the way from the mainland."
另外，我们终于能和蕾亚娜所说的那个紧密联系的尼豪岛群体中的某个人交谈了——其实是普拉尼的妹妹，她也不想在广播里出现她的声音。她说，“我们喜欢尼豪岛现在的样子。我相信鲁滨逊家族在保持这种状态。他们真的是好人。老实说，如果你是一个岛的主人但住在考艾岛，你会免费支付驳船的燃料送人过去，而且对他们运往尼豪岛的每个箱子都不收费吗？这对我们意义重大。他们真的照顾人民。真不敢相信你们竟然从大陆一路过来。”
Thinking about all the rules on Niihau and the way they're implemented, at some point, I started to wonder. Should they even keep it going? When we were talking to Pulani, who clearly has a lot of problems with the way the island is run, we asked him about that. And he told us this story about his brother Iaone.
想到尼豪岛上所有的规则以及它们的实施方式，在某种程度上，我开始想。他们甚至应该继续维持下去吗？当我们和普拉尼交谈时，他显然对岛屿的管理方式有很多不满，我们问了他关于这方面的问题。他给我们讲了一个关于他哥哥伊奥内的事。
Iaone's married and has kids. He lived on Niihau all his life until he decided to try to make a go of it in modern life. So he moved on to Kauai with his family and got a job driving semi trucks-- delivery trucks. But he used to complain to Pulani about how expensive everything was. And then one day, he just disappeared.
伊奥内结婚并有了孩子。他一生都住在尼豪岛，直到他决定尝试在现代生活中闯荡。所以他和家人搬到了考艾岛，找到了一份驾驶半挂卡车——送货卡车的工作。但他过去常向普拉尼抱怨一切是多么昂贵。然后有一天，他突然消失了。
And I got a call from his boss asking me, oh, where's your brother? I was like, I don't know. You should tell me. He works for you. And he was like, oh, he didn't show up to work for three days now. No call, no show, no nothing.
我接到他老板的电话问我，噢，你哥哥在哪？我就想，我不知道。你应该告诉我。他为你工作。他说，噢，他已经三天没来上班了。没电话，没露面，什么都没有。
So Pulani calls one of their sisters, who also lives on Kauai, and he says, do you know where our brother is?
所以普拉尼给他们的一位也住在考艾岛的姐妹打了电话，他说，你知道我们哥哥在哪吗？
She started to laugh. She said, he went back. I said, what do you mean he went back? Yeah, he went back to Niihau. He picked up his family and went back to Niihau. When I finally talked to him, he said he was just over it. To him, it was harder to pay taxes, buy a car, keep up with the registration, rent a house, pay for the electricity, the water, gas. And not getting nowhere, living from paycheck to paycheck. He said he was more happy back home living off the land, living each day for that day. Because next day, it's a new day.
她开始笑。她说，他回去了。我说，你是说回去了是什么意思？是的，他回到了尼豪岛。他接上家人回到了尼豪岛。当我最终和他交谈时，他说他只是受够了。对他来说，付税、买车、跟上登记、租房、付电费、水费、煤气费更难。而且一事无成，靠工资生活。他说他在家乡靠土地生活，过一天算一天更快乐。因为第二天，又是新的一天。
So he had a harder time abiding by the rules--
所以他在遵守规则方面遇到了更多困难——
Of modern life than to the rules of the island of Robinson. He said he can put up with that.
现代生活比鲁滨逊岛的规则。他说他能忍受那个。
And Pulani later told us his brother Iaone, he's back living on Kauai now. He broke one of the rules. Pulani didn't say what it was, but Iaone was asked to leave Niihau, and he hopes that one day he'll be allowed back.
后来普拉尼告诉我们，他的哥哥伊奥内现在又住在考艾岛了。他打破了一条规则。普拉尼没说是哪条，但伊奥内被要求离开尼豪岛，他希望有一天能被允许回去。
Sean Cole and Adia White. Coming up, the head of one of the biggest financial institutions on the planet, a homeless guy, and one of our own producers all get called in on the same day in front of the same judge and the same set of rules. Who comes out on top? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
肖恩·科尔和阿迪亚·怀特。接下来，地球上最大的金融机构之一的负责人、一个无家可归的人，以及我们自己的制作人之一，都在同一天被叫到同一位法官面前，面对同一套规则。谁会胜出？芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续播出，一分钟后见。
We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, A Dave in Court.
我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，戴夫在法庭上。
A little while ago, one of our producers, David Kestenbaum, broke one of the rules that we in our country have decided all to abide by. He made a left-hand turn by a sign that says no left-hand turns. As a result, he ended up spending the day in the courtroom of this one judge. This judge who applied the rules with a fastidious consistency that's sometimes lacking on privately-owned Hawaiian islands. We thought it might be nice to end our show today by seeing what that's like exactly. Here's David.
不久前，我们的制作人之一大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆打破了我们国家决定大家都必须遵守的一条规则。他在一个写着“禁止左转”的标志旁左转了。结果，他最终在法官的法庭上度过了一天。这位法官以一种在私人拥有的夏威夷岛屿上有时缺乏的细致一致性来应用规则。我们认为今天结束节目时看看那是怎样的确切情形会很不错。这是大卫。
If the Supreme Court is the highest court in the land, this is basically the lowest. It's a municipal court. This one is for two towns in New Jersey. Still, the courtroom is an intimidating place. Wood paneling, wood seats, a giant official seal on the wall. In front of that, the judge's bench, which is raised like this physical reminder of who is in charge. There are a couple dozen of us here to have our cases heard.
如果最高法院是全国最高的法院，这基本上是最低的。这是一个市法院。这个是给新泽西州的两个城镇用的。尽管如此，法庭仍然是一个令人生畏的地方。木镶板，木座椅，墙上有一个巨大的官方印章。在那前面，是法官席，像这样物理提醒谁在负责。我们这里有几十个人要听审案件。
All rise for the honorable Clarence Barry-Austin.
全体起立，请克拉伦斯·巴里-奥斯汀法官入席。
Judge Clarence Barry-Austin walks in, black robe. And if you're hoping to be home in an hour, it's not going to happen. Here's how he starts.
克拉伦斯·巴里-奥斯汀法官走了进来，穿着黑袍。如果你希望一小时内回家，那是不可能的。他是这样开始的。
Now, the information I'm about to communicate to you will take a few minutes to do so, perhaps more than a few minutes.
现在，我即将传达给你们的信息需要几分钟，也许比几分钟还要多。
I know the word few can mean more than three. In this case, it means 22-- which is longer, by the way, than this entire story will be. He gives this long list of rules and information and more rules.
我知道“几分钟”这个词可能意味着超过三分钟。在这种情况下，意味着22分钟——顺便说一句，比整个故事的时间还要长。他列出了很长的规则、信息和更多规则。
I have to accept your guilty plea. I have to evaluate that plea to determine that it is an acceptable plea of court--
我必须接受你们的有罪抗辩。我必须评估该抗辩，以确定它是否是一个法庭可接受的抗辩——
The judge wants people to know all this stuff for their own protection, but he has another reason, as well. There is this much grander mission that he's on, though it doesn't come up until minute 20. And it's easy to miss.
法官想让人们了解所有这些事情是为了保护他们自己，但他也有另一个原因。他肩负着一个更宏大的使命，尽管直到第20分钟才提到。而且很容易被错过。
It is important to the court that you leave here fully understanding our procedures, our protocols, and the circumstances surrounding your particular case. Whether you are happy with the result is less important to you. Really, frankly, it's less important to me--
对于法庭来说，重要的是你们离开这里时能完全理解我们的程序、协议以及围绕你们特定案件的情况。无论你们对结果是否满意，对你们来说都不重要。说实话，对我来说也不那么重要——
He wants people to leave the court understanding how our legal system works. I talked to Barry-Austin about this. Months later, we sat down to do an interview. He says it's part of their training for municipal courts because, for some people coming in, their little traffic case could be their only contact with the legal system ever-- the only time they're in an actual court having their case heard, with all that wood paneling around them.
他希望人们离开法庭时能理解我们的法律体系是如何运作的。我和巴里-奥斯汀谈过这件事。几个月后，我们坐下来做了一次采访。他说这是他们市法院培训的一部分，因为对于一些进来的人来说，他们的小交通案件可能是他们唯一一次与法律体系的接触——他们唯一一次在真正的法庭上听到自己的案件被审理，周围有所有的木镶板。
That's one of the things that we talk about, the fact that it's important that they have a good experience, and a fair and an impartial experience here because this is where people will determine what they think of the judiciary as a whole.
这是我们谈论的事情之一，事实上，他们在这里有良好的体验、公平和公正的体验非常重要，因为这就是人们决定他们对司法整体看法的地方。
Everything. Like up to the Supreme Court, like all the cases they read about in the newspaper.
一切。就像最高法院，就像他们在报纸上读到的所有案件一样。
Absolutely. They get a sense that judiciary functions in a fair and impartial way-- and a compassionate way.
绝对。他们感觉到司法系统以公平公正的方式运作——而且是一种富有同情心的方式。
What makes this mission hard is that I and all the people around me here are on a mission of our own, and it is not the same mission. From what I can tell from our chitchat on the way in, a bunch of us are here because we are sure we should not have gotten the ticket. I fell into this category. We want the judge to waive the ticket, or at least reduce the fine, or something.
使这一使命变得困难的是，我和我周围的所有人都在执行我们自己的使命，而且那并不是同一个使命。从我们进来时的闲聊中我可以看出，我们中有一群人在这里是因为我们确信我们不应该收到那张罚单。我属于这一类。我们希望法官免除罚单，或者至少减少罚款，或者什么别的。
Put your left hand on the Bible. Right hand raised.
左手放在圣经上。右手举起。
Case in point-- and by that I mean case in point. This is a guy who we'll call Jeff. Jeff is upset about his ticket. He parked his car on the street overnight, which is not allowed. There are signs for it all over town. But he is pleading not guilty. So they have this little mini trial. He doesn't have a lawyer or anything. It's just him.
举个例子——我的意思是举个例子。这就是我们称之为杰夫的人。杰夫对他的罚单感到愤怒。他把车停在街上过夜，这是不允许的。全城到处都是标志。但他抗辩无罪。所以他们有一个小型的简易审判。他没有律师或什么的。只有他自己。
This procedure's a little different than you may be accustomed to.
这个程序和你可能习惯的有点不同。
I know, Your Honor. I've been coming here for about 14 years now.
我知道，法官阁下。我已经来这里大约14年了。
You've been coming here for about 14 years?
你已经来这里大约14年了？
Grew up in this town.
在这个镇上长大。
OK. You've been coming to court for 14 years?
好的。你已经来法庭14年了？
Well, you know, with school. I went to school at Seton Hall.
嗯，你知道，上学的时候。我在西顿霍尔上学。
All right. Well, I just wanted to--
好的。嗯，我只是想——
I think Jeff is just trying to establish that he's a local. The kind of person who deserves a break. He launches into his defense, which is that he lives basically right on the border between two towns. In one town, it's illegal to park on the street overnight. But in the other town, it's legal. He says there are no signs showing where the border is. Though when he lays all this out, the whole thing gets a little garbled because-- I saw this a few times when people go to court-- they sometimes try to use legal terms like they've seen on Law and Order or something.
我觉得杰夫只是想确立他是一个本地人。那种理应得到宽容的人。他开始了辩护，他说他基本上住在两个城镇的边界上。在一个镇，晚上在街上停车是非法的。但在另一个镇，是合法的。他说没有标志显示边界在哪里。虽然当他阐述这一切时，整个事情变得有点混乱，因为——我几次看到当人们去法庭时——他们有时尝试使用法律术语，就像他们在《法律与秩序》或其他节目中看到的那样。
--this one, and that's why I came here, Your Honor. To actually show evidence that there's no actual proof, beyond a reasonable doubt, for an individual that goes in there, like myself-- I've been living there-- to know that that particular side of the street where the border is between two towns, to know exactly if he was parking in South Orange or in North.
——这一个，这就是我来这里的原因，法官阁下。为了真正展示证据，对于像我这样进去的个人，没有什么真正的证明，排除合理怀疑——我一直住在那里——能够知道两个城镇之间的边界在哪条街那一侧，能够确切知道他是在南奥兰治还是在北边停车。
As I indicated in my opening statement, parking tickets are a little different.
正如我在开场陈述中所指出的，停车罚单有点不同。
Judge Barry-Austin is very patient with him. He told me people often come in just wanting to be heard, so he listens. But also-- this is the mission, remember-- he wants the guy to know how our system works, how the law works.
巴里-奥斯汀法官对他非常有耐心。他告诉我，人们进来通常只是想被倾听，所以他听了。但也——记住这是使命——他想让这个人了解我们的系统是如何运作的，法律是如何运作的。
Let me just inform you that motor vehicle rules of the road don't require intent. Criminal laws require you to intent to violate the law. Motor vehicle laws don't require intent. So if you parked illegally-- even if you don't intend to park illegally, if you are, in fact, parked illegally, that's a violation.
我只是通知你，机动车道路规则不需要主观意图。刑法要求你有违法意图。机动车法不需要意图。所以如果你违法停车——即使你不打算违法停车，如果你实际上违法停车了，那就是违法。
Jeff plows ahead anyway. He enters 11 photos into evidence. He runs through them one by one. Photos of the street signs, and the lack of street signs. Close-ups of street signs. A photo of a fire hydrant, for some reason. Of a car parked in the same spot he was parked in on a different night. That car didn't get a ticket. The whole thing takes about 15 minutes. And then the judge issues his ruling.
杰夫依然坚持推进。他提交了11张照片作为证据。他一张一张地展示。街道标志的照片，以及街道标志缺失的照片。街道标志的特写。不知为何有一张消防栓的照片。一张他在不同晚上停在同一位置的汽车的照片。那辆车没拿到罚单。整个过程花了大约15分钟。然后法官发布了他的裁决。
Your defense really is not an approved defense. I'm satisfied that all the necessary proofs are in place for me and supports a finding of guilty of this particular offense. The fine for the offense, sir, is $60.
你的辩护确实不是一个被批准的辩护。我确信所有必要的证据都在这里，支持我发现你触犯了这条特定罪行。先生，该罪行的罚款是60美元。
Jeff went off to pay his fine, pretty clearly feeling like justice had not been done here.
杰夫去支付了他的罚款，很明显感觉这里没有实现正义。
How do you think he felt at the end of that?
你觉得他在最后感觉如何？
I'm sure he felt frustrated.
我敢肯定他感到沮丧。
Didn't you have some discretion? I mean, this guy, he's walking in there super frustrated. He's lived here his whole life. There are no signs there. Could you have given him a break?
难道你没有裁量权吗？我的意思是，这个人，他走进去时超级沮丧。他一辈子都住在这里。那里没有标志。你不能通融一下吗？
I could have suspended his fine, yes.
我可以中止他的罚款，是的。
Oh, you could have?
噢，你可以吗？
I could've.
我可以。
Why didn't you?
为什么你不那么做？
Because he violated the law. People go through stop signs and say, I didn't see the stop sign. What would make his situation different from anybody else who said, Judge, I didn't know?
因为他违法了。人们闯过停车标志，然后说，我没看到停车标志。是什么让他的情况与任何其他说“法官，我不知道”的人不同呢？
Barry-Austin was born in Guyana. Neither of his parents went to college, but he told me he wanted to work with the law as long as he can remember. He liked arguing things, sorting through the logic of things. He has faith in the idea of laws, that rules, words on a page, can be clearly applied to the real world. And yet, even here, with these little cases, you see how hard that can be-- like with this one man.
巴里-奥斯汀出生在圭亚那。他的父母都没有上过大学，但他告诉我，只要他记事起他就想从事法律工作。他喜欢辩论事情，梳理事情的逻辑。他信仰法律的概念，即规则、页面上的文字，可以清晰地应用于现实世界。然而，即使在这里，处理这些小案件，你也能看到那有多难——就像这个男人一样。
He'd gotten a ticket, I think, for being too far into the intersection when he stopped for a red light. His English isn't so good.
他拿到了一张罚单，我想，是因为他在红灯停车时开进了十字路口太远。他的英语不太好。
Yes, something I understand.
是的，有些我明白了。
Now, is it a hearing problem or is it a language problem? Do you understand English?
现在，是听力问题还是语言问题？你懂英语吗？
No, no, no. No problem with hearing, no. It's OK.
不，不，不。听力没问题，没问题。OK。
You can hear OK? You hear everything I'm saying?
你能听到吗？你听到我说的每一句话了吗？
Yes, OK.
是的，OK。
Do you understand everything I'm saying?
你明白我说的每一件事吗？
Yes. Understand something.
是的。明白一些。
What language do you speak, sir?
先生，你说什么语言？
Ukrainian, Russian, Polish.
乌克兰语、俄语、波兰语。
The guy just wants to plead guilty. But the judge, admirably, wants to make sure the man clearly understands what's happening. So he tries to get an interpreter. The courts are set up to do this, though the mechanism seems a little low-tech.
这个人只是想认罪。但法官，令人钦佩的是，想确保那个人清楚地理解发生了什么。所以他试着找一个口译员。法庭设置了这样做，尽管机制看起来有点低技术含量。
[PHONE DIALING]
[电话拨号]
The judge calls up an interpreter service, basically on a speakerphone in the court.
法官在法庭上基本上通过免提电话呼叫口译服务。
Welcome to LanguageLine Solutions. For Spanish, press 1. For other, press 2.
欢迎来到语言热线解决方案。西班牙语请按1。其他请按2。
[BEEP]
[嘟声]
[HOLD MUSIC PLAYING]
[保留音乐]
The judge tells them he needs a Polish interpreter. And after a bit, a woman comes on who speaks Polish. The judge has to swear her in.
法官告诉他们他需要一名波兰语口译员。过了一会儿，一位说波兰语的女士出现了。法官必须让她宣誓。
Do you solemnly swear--
你庄严宣誓——
This all takes time. Everyone in court just has to wait. Then the judge starts over with the man. The woman on the phone translates for the judge.
这一切都需要时间。法庭上的每个人都只能等着。然后法官开始和那个人重新开始。电话里的女士为法官翻译。
[SPEAKING POLISH]
[讲波兰语]
It's not Polish language.
这不是波兰语。
Didn't you say that you would prefer to speak in Polish?
你不是说你更愿意说波兰语吗？
Ukrainian. Ukrainian, Russian, no problem.
乌克兰语。乌克兰语，俄语，没问题。
I thought you said Polish, no problem. Didn't you say that?
我以为你说波兰语没问题。你不是那么说的吗？
The judge has to do the whole thing again. Find a Ukrainian interpreter.
法官必须把整件事再做一遍。找一名乌克兰语口译员。
[SPEAKING UKRAINIAN]
[讲乌克兰语]
This went on for over a half an hour. Even with the interpreter, the judge isn't convinced the man totally understands, so he schedules the trial for another day. All this to try to resolve a minor traffic violation. I found it grueling, and also impressive.
这持续了半个多小时。即使有口译员，法官也不确信那个人完全理解，所以他把审判安排在了另一天。所有这些都是为了解决一个轻微的交通违规。我觉得这令人筋疲力尽，但也令人印象深刻。
Most of the cases didn't take that long. The judge cranked through 27 different defendants in a little over five hours. There was a guy who'd been caught with a small amount of marijuana. And weirdly, a case against the CEO of JP Morgan Chase, the largest bank in America. I thought maybe he'd blown a stop sign or something, but it was about a property that hadn't been kept up. And it turned out neither he nor the bank had any connection to the building, so it got dismissed. And then there was one woman who'd been in a minor accident. She testified that the other car had quote, "appeared out of nowhere," which I'm pretty sure violates the law-- of physics.
大多数案件没花那么长时间。法官在五个多小时内解决了27名不同的被告。有一个家伙被抓到携带少量大麻。而且奇怪的是，一个针对摩根大通银行——美国最大银行——首席执行官的案件。我想也许他闯了停车标志或什么的，但它是关于一处房产没维护好。结果他和银行都与那栋建筑没关系，所以被驳回了。然后有一位女士卷入了一场轻微事故。她作证说另一辆车“凭空出现”，我相当确定这触犯了物理定律。
Some people did seem OK with how things went. One man, when his case was over, told the judge to have a blessed day. Another man who had pulled into a handicapped spot apologized. The most fascinating case of the day, though, the one where you saw just how hard it could sometimes be to apply the law, was this one.
有些人看起来对事情的结果还算满意。一名男子，当他的案件结束时，祝法官度过一个受祝福的一天。另一名因停在残疾人车位而道歉的男子。当天最引人入胜的案件，即你可以看到有时应用法律是多么困难的一个，是这一个。
Just speak up. Say who you are, name and address.
大声说出来。报上你的名字、姓名和地址。
The guy says his name. Then, for address--
那个家伙报了他的名字。然后，对于地址——
I don't have an address.
我没有地址。
By that, are you asserting that you're homeless?
通过这一点，你是在声称你无家可归吗？
Yes, sir.
是的，先生。
The man's wearing a long-sleeved button-up shirt that is too big and untucked. He's standing with his legs really far apart, as if maybe he'd worked out that that was the most stable way to stand to keep from falling over.
那个人穿着一件长袖衬衫，太大了，没塞进裤子里。他双腿叉开站着，好像也许他算出来那是为了防止摔倒的最稳定的站立方式。
Judge Barry-Austin goes through the papers. He sees that the man is in for basically drinking in public. It's an open container violation. The ticket was issued years ago and never paid.
巴里-奥斯汀法官翻阅文件。他看到这个男人基本上是因为公共场合饮酒。这是一个公开容器违规。罚单是几年前开的，从来没付过。
Which has gone back to 2013.
可以追溯到2013年。
Yes. It took me a little while to get here. Sorry.
是的。我花了一些时间才来到这里。抱歉。
I don't know how to take that, but I hope you don't mean that to be funny.
我不知道该怎么回应这一点，但我希望你不是想开玩笑。
The prosecutor has recommended that the whole thing be dismissed. But Barry-Austin is not on board. He looks down at the ticket. The court had tried to get the man to appear many times.
检察官建议驳回整件事。但巴里-奥斯汀不赞同。他看向罚单。法庭曾多次试图让该男子出庭。
I mean, there are multiple times. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 that I can quickly count. The court has expended an enormous amount of time, effort, and expense in just trying to get him into court.
我的意思是，有多次。1、2、3、4、5、6、7，我能很快数出来。法庭在仅仅试图让他出庭方面花费了巨大的时间、精力和金钱。
I'm willing to dismiss the original ticket, he says, but shouldn't there be some penalty for failing to appear in court so many times? At this point, the homeless man, unwisely, speaks up.
我愿意驳回最初的罚单，他说，但不应该为多次不出庭受到某种惩罚吗？此时，那个无家可归的男人，不明智地开口了。
I've been homeless for approximately eight years, sir.
我已经无家可归大约八年了，先生。
OK. But at the same time, you did get the ticket, did you not?
好的。但与此同时，你确实拿到了罚单，不是吗？
I got the ticket and I lost it or threw it away. I don't know what I did with it.
我拿到罚单然后弄丢了或扔掉了。我不知道我拿它干什么了。
[SCOFFS]
[冷笑]
You see what I'm-- you lost it or you threw it away? You know, it's just a total disregard for the process. That's what's bothering me, OK? I mean, being homeless doesn't prevent you from at least abiding by the process of the court.
你明白我的意思吗……你弄丢了或扔掉了？你知道，这是对整个过程的完全无视。这就是困扰我的地方，好的？我的意思是，无家可归并不妨碍你至少遵守法庭的程序。
Of course, the judge is all about applying the process of the court. A woman steps up to testify on the homeless man's behalf. She says she knows him because he comes to her food pantry. He volunteers there, too. She says he comes in three days a week, four hours a day.
当然，法官所做的一切都是为了应用法庭的程序。一位女士站出来为那个无家可归的男人作证。她说她认识他，因为他来到她的食品分发处。他也在那里做志愿者。她说他每周来三天，每天四小时。
It's a lot of work, and he needs medical care. He has seizures. I've witnessed them. He's going to the hospital. I take him home from the hospital.
那有很多工作，而且他需要医疗护理。他有癫痫发作。我目睹过它们。他去医院。我带他从医院回家。
She says she's been trying to help get him on Medicaid, but someone told her he can't be on Medicaid because of this outstanding ticket. I later learned that's probably not correct. But that's why she brought him in.
她说她一直在努力帮助他申请医疗补助，但有人告诉她他不能申请医疗补助，因为这张未付的罚单。我后来了解到这可能是不正确的。但这就是她带他来的原因。
So we're trying to go through all the processes, and it's taking a long time.
所以我们正在尝试通过所有程序，这需要很长时间。
So if I'm understanding you correct, it wasn't even at his initiative that he's here today? It's at your initiative?
所以如果我没理解错，今天他来这甚至不是他的主意？而是你的主意？
Because he forgot all about it. I'm sure he did. And he shouldn't have.
因为他把这全忘了。我敢肯定他忘了。他不应该这样。
This is where the mission gets tough. Judge Barry-Austin goes back and forth about what to do, just thinking aloud. I don't see how I can let this go, he says. He can't just not show up for court so many times and there not be any consequence. On the other hand, he recognizes the guy will have a hard time paying a penalty. There will probably be additional cost to the court to try to collect it. But in the end, he decides to issue a $50 fine for failing to appear. And then, almost as an afterthought, he asks this.
这就是使命变得困难的地方。巴里-奥斯汀法官反复思考该怎么做，只是大声思考。我不明白我怎么能让这件事过去，他说。他不能只是这么多次不出庭而没有后果。另一方面，他认识到那个家伙将很难支付罚款。可能法庭试图收取罚款还会产生额外成本。但最终，他决定对不出庭处以50美元的罚款。然后，几乎就像事后想到的，他问了这个问题。
Does he get paid at all for his work at the--
他在这工作得到报酬吗——
They're all volunteers. We'll pay court costs, whatever it is, sir.
他们全是志愿者。我们会支付法庭费用，不管是什么，先生。
The program will take care of that for him?
项目会为他承担费用？
We'll take care of it, absolutely, because he needs medical help.
我们会承担，绝对，因为他需要医疗援助。
All right. OK. Um...
好的。好的。嗯……
Barry-Austin was just trying to apply the law-- the law that he believes in. And yet, he was in a bind. He decided to issue this fine to punish a guy for not showing up in court, but now the guy wasn't even going to end up paying the fine because now it's going to come out of the budget of a food pantry. What to do?
巴里-奥斯汀只是试图应用法律——他所信仰的法律。然而，他陷入了困境。他决定开这张罚单来惩罚一个不出庭的家伙，但现在那个家伙甚至不会去付这张罚单，因为现在它将从一个食品分发处的预算中支出。该怎么办？
When I interviewed Barry-Austin about this day in court, it was a couple months after the fact. He was curious how it came out, too.
当我采访巴里-奥斯汀关于法庭上的这一天时，那是几个月后的事了。他也很好奇结果如何。
How did it turn out? Do you recall?
结果如何？你还记得吗？
What do you think you did?
你认为你做了什么？
What would I have done? I don't want to venture a guess. Tell me how it worked out.
我会做什么？我不想冒险猜测。告诉我它是怎么解决的。
Here, I'll play it for you.
在这，我放给你听。
All right. You know what? Since I don't want to impose that cost upon the program. I don't want to impose it. I'm going to suspend it.
好的。你知道吗？既然我不想把成本强加给这个项目。我不想强加它。我决定中止它。
He lets it go. No penalty. Barry-Austin told me this is one thing that thwarts him occasionally-- human kindness. The usual way it happens is that someone, an adult, will be assessed a fine, and then the person will look to the back of the courtroom and an older parent or grandparent will come forward to pay it.
他让它过去了。没有惩罚。巴里-奥斯汀告诉我这是偶尔挫败他的一件事——人类的善良。通常发生的情况是，某人，一个成年人，被评估罚款，然后那个人会看向法庭后面，一位年长的父母或祖父母会站出来支付。
Why are you paying? It's his. I mean, he's not a child. He's a grown person. Why are you-- I can't tell you not to pay. And I won't tell you not to pay. But it just irritates me. I always tell my kids, I will never let you fall and crash and burn. I will always be that last resort that you have to. But you have to learn lessons from the things that you do. And the rules are the rules.
你为什么要付钱？这是他的。我的意思是，他不是个孩子。他是个成年人。你为什么要——我不能告诉你别付钱。我不会告诉你别付钱。但这只是激怒了我。我总是告诉我的孩子们，我永远不会让你们跌倒并崩溃、烧毁。我永远会是你们有的最后一道防线。但你们必须从自己做的事情中学到教训。规则就是规则。
The rules are the rules. I have just one more case for you.
规则就是规则。我还有一个案子给你们。
State versus David Kestenbaum.
州诉大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。
That's me. Before I play you the tape-- which is excruciating for me to listen to now-- remember, I was one of the people who was convinced they had been wronged. I'd made the left turn, sure, into a parking space. But I had no idea it was illegal. There is a sign, but honestly, you can't see it until after you've already made the turn. And given that, the penalty just seemed unfair. $85 plus three points on your license. After it happened, I would pass by that spot every day on my way to work, and every day I would be filled with outrage that I'd gotten the ticket.
那是我的。在我放录音之前——现在听起来让我痛苦——记住，我是那些确信自己被冤枉的人之一。我转了左弯，确定，进了一个停车位。但我根本不知道那是非法的。有一个标志，但老实说，你只有在转弯后才能看到它。鉴于此，惩罚看起来很不公平。85美元外加驾照扣3分。事情发生后，我每天上班路上都会经过那个地点，每天我都会因为拿到了罚单而充满愤怒。
I'd been compulsively running through what I would say in court in my head for weeks. So that day, I dressed up. I wore a tie. I had my manila envelope with photos in it, and data. I'd measured the distance from where I'd made the turn to where the sign is. I was nervous to be there in court, but I also felt like, I'm a rule-follower. If there's a sign that says no left turns, I don't make a left turn. So I felt like, I'm not against these people, the judge and the prosecutor. There'd just been some sort of mistake. We were going to sort it out. I see now how stupid that was.
几个星期以来，我一直在强迫性地在脑海里演练我在法庭上会说什么。所以那天，我精心打扮。我系了领带。我带了一个马尼拉信封，里面有照片和数据。我测量了从我转弯的地方到标志的地方的距离。我在法庭上很紧张，但我也觉得，我是一个遵守规则的人。如果有写着“禁止左转”的标志，我就不左转。所以我感觉，我不是针对这些人，法官和检察官。只是出现了一些错误。我们会把它整理好的。我现在看到那有多愚蠢了。
When I arrived in court, I'd waited in line to see the prosecutor, who'd looked at my driving record, which was clean, and he'd offered me a plea bargain. I'd plead guilty to a lesser charge-- obstructing the flow of traffic, which did not come with any points-- and he said I could explain to the judge about the signs. Maybe he would reduce the fine. That seemed great. It seemed like the way the system was supposed to work. I knew it. These were my people. We all want the same thing. Here's what happened when I got before Judge Barry-Austin.
当我到达法庭时，我排队去见检察官，他看了我的驾驶记录，那是干净的，他向我提出了认罪协商。我以较轻的罪名认罪——阻碍交通流，没有扣分——他说我可以向法官解释关于标志的事。也许他会减少罚款。那看起来很棒。看起来这就是系统应该运作的方式。我了解它。这些人是我的人。我们都想要同样的东西。这就是当我出现在巴里-奥斯汀法官面前时发生的事情。
Good afternoon, sir. Your name, your address, please.
下午好，先生。你的名字，你的地址，请。
David Kestenbaum.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。
It started according to plan.
它开始按照计划进行。
You also were charged with making a left turn into a parking space on Sloane Street?
你还被指控在斯隆街左转进了一个停车位？
That's correct.
那是正确的。
Prosecutor's moving to amend that to a violation of Title 39:4-67. Again, obstruction of traffic. You understand the amendment that's being proposed?
检察官请求修改为触犯Title 39:4-67。再次，阻碍交通。你理解正在提出的修改吗？
I do.
我理解。
And you're pleading guilty to obstructing traffic through the maneuver of making a left turn into the parking space?
你承认以左转进入停车位的动作阻碍了交通的罪行？
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
If I had been paying more attention to Judge Barry-Austin's 22-minute introductory speech, I think I might have avoided what came next. Remember this?
如果我当时更多地注意巴里-奥斯汀法官的22分钟开场演讲，我想我可能避免了接下来发生的事情。记得这个吗？
I have to accept your guilty plea. I have to evaluate that plea to determine that it is an acceptable plea according to the standards and the guidelines that I have to follow.
我必须接受你们的有罪抗辩。我必须评估该抗辩，以确定它是否是符合我必须遵循的标准和准则的可接受抗辩。
I was not paying attention at all. When I stood in front of the judge, he told me he had to establish a factual basis for my plea. I was pleading guilty to obstructing the flow of traffic, so he asked, did I obstruct the flow of traffic by making that left-hand turn? If I had just answered yes, I would have been fine. But I didn't remember any cars. And I was still hoping that, when he understood my situation, he'd give me a break on the fine. So here's what I said when he asked, were you obstructing the flow of traffic?
我根本没注意。当我站在法官面前时，他告诉我他必须为我的抗辩建立事实基础。我正在承认阻碍交通流的罪行，所以他问，我通过左转阻碍了交通流吗？如果我当时直接回答“是”，我就没事了。但我记不起有任何车。而且我还在希望当他理解我的情况时，他会在罚款上通融一下。所以这是当我被问到“你当时阻碍了交通流吗”时说的话。
There were no other cars around, but I understand it would impede the flow. Yes.
附近没有其他车，但我明白它会阻碍交通。是的。
No. No, it doesn't work like that, sir.
不。不，事情不是那样运作的，先生。
I'm sorry.
抱歉。
It doesn't work like that. I need a factual basis. If there was no other vehicles then--
它不是那样运作的。我需要事实基础。如果当时没有其他车辆，那么——
There were other vehicles in the area.
该地区有其他车辆。
No, no, you-- you can't acknowledge to me on the record that there were no other vehicles and then say that you impeded traffic. I can't accept that.
不，不，你……你不能在记录上向我承认没有其他车辆，然后说你阻碍了交通。我不能接受。
Can I give a fuller explanation?
我可以给出一个完整的解释吗？
Can I give a fuller explanation? God, who talks like that? Me, I guess. I'd started doing that thing I'd seen other people do. I tried to use legal language I had no business using.
我可以给出一个完整的解释吗？上帝，谁会那样说话？我，我想。我开始做我看到别人做的那种事。我尝试使用我根本没权利使用的法律语言。
I mean, I'm not going to allow to just totally disavow what you've already said. If you want to explain it to me in a fashion that would bring you within the violation, I'll listen to that. What I don't want you to tell me--
我的意思是，我不会允许你完全否认你已经说的话。如果你想以一种能将你带入违规范围的方式向我解释，我会听那个。我不想让你告诉我——
I'm going to tell you this because I just want to make sure we're understanding each other.
我会告诉你这个，因为我只是想确保我们互相理解。
All right. Go ahead.
好的。继续。
I was coming off the circle. I went into the parking area. I made a left-hand turn. To my recollection, I do not recall any traffic coming in the opposite direction.
我从圆盘处过来。我进入了停车区。我左转了。据我记忆，我不记得有任何从相反方向过来的交通。
So you don't recall that, in fact, you impeded the flow of traffic in either direction?
所以你不记得，实际上，你在任何方向都阻碍了交通流？
If impede the flow of traffic means there has to be a car present there at the time, then no.
如果“阻碍交通流”意味着那时必须有车在场，那么没有。
OK, then I can't accept this as a-- there is no factual basis.
好的，那么我不能接受这个作为——没有事实基础。
I-- I-- I-- I apologize.
我……我……我……我道歉。
I am a person who is used to speaking in public. It's, like, my job. But I could barely think straight. In my head, this went on forever, though apparently it was 3 minutes and 45 seconds, according to the tape. In the end, he refused to accept the plea bargain.
我是一个习惯在公众面前发言的人。这就像是我的工作。但我几乎无法冷静思考。在我的脑海里，这持续了很久，尽管根据录音显然是3分45秒。最后，他拒绝接受认罪协商。
You know how nervous I was coming into court that day?
你知道我那天进法庭时有多紧张吗？
Well, now I do.
嗯，现在我知道了。
It felt strange, but we talked about my case a little.
这感觉很奇怪，但我们讨论了我的案子一点。
I have to hope that you'll be satisfied with the outcome, but--
我必须希望你们对结果满意，但是——
I wasn't satis-- I wasn't satisfied with the outcome.
我不满——我对结果不满意。
That's not my driving motivation. It's more that the process work, and that you're satisfied that the process worked. Even if you are dissatisfied with the outcome, that you're satisfied that the process worked.
那不是我的驾驶动力。更多的是过程起作用，并且你确信过程起作用了。即使你对结果不满意，你确信过程起作用了。
I certainly admired your desire to apply the law in a clear way.
我确实钦佩你以清晰方式应用法律的愿望。
Well, that's the job.
嗯，那是工作。
I told him, genuinely, I thought he had succeeded in his mission with me. It seemed fair. I'd learned something. He said, OK. One victory for the day.
我真诚地告诉他，我认为他在我身上成功完成了他的使命。这看起来很公平。我学到了一些东西。他说，好的。今天的一场胜利。
David Kestenbaum. He's one of the producers of our show.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。他是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - NAS FEAT. LAURYN HILL, "IF I RULED THE WORLD (IMAGINE THAT)"]
[音乐 - Nas Feat. Lauryn Hill, "If I Ruled the World (Imagine That)"]
Our program was produced today by Susan Burton. Other staff, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivas, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Christopher Swetala, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Diane Wu. Music help today from Damien Graef.
我们的节目今天由苏珊·伯顿制作。其他员工，佐伊·切斯、达纳·奇瓦斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德鲁明、凯伦·达芬、斯蒂芬妮·傅、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、塞斯·林德、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、罗宾·塞米恩、莉莉·沙利文、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克和黛安·吴。今天来自达米恩·格拉夫的音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, before going into public radio, he trained for years in the space program as an astronaut but decided not to go on his mission to the International Space Station when he learned about everything he was going to have to leave behind.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，在进入公共广播之前，他在太空计划中接受了多年的宇航员训练，但当他得知他将不得不留下的一切时，决定不去执行他的国际空间站任务。
Like not having any snacks, not having any LEGOs, not having anything fun. Yeah.
比如没有零食，没有乐高，没有有趣的东西。是的。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。